hi there today we'll look at block wise
parallel decoding for deep ultra
aggressive models by Mitchell Stern
know'm shazier and Jakob bouche correct
of UC Berkeley and Google brain so this
is a bit more of an engineering paper
than usual which is which I find cool
it's it's basically an engineering trick
to get these ultra aggressive models to
decode faster while you can either
preserve fully their performance or
suffer a bit of a drop in performance
while even speeding them up more all
right so let's dive in actually the the
paper starts out with a description of
what auto regressive models are and what
decoding is in them so let me try to
quickly quickly explain this so an ultra
what is an auto regressive model
so basically we're talking about let's
say language models so language models
are the classic examples of these models
where you have a language model is a
model that simply predicts the next word
in a sequence so you could have
something like a cat sits on the and
then here is blank so the language model
is asked to predict which word is the
word that follows the language model
basically does this by predicting the
probability distribution over the next
world so W T plus 1 if this is this is T
here this is T minus 1 and so on table T
wasn't given all the W is smaller or
equal than T so all the words come
before should lead to the next were
being predicted so the language model is
task to ask what is the next word in
this sequence or what's the probability
distribution over the next word and then
you can simply you know
pick the maximum probability word or
something like this so that's that's
pretty standard so far so what is the
autoregressive part in here so basically
that the autoregressive part means that
in order for me to find this word here
this next word I will look at all of
these words here and what does it mean
then when I want to use this language
model for generating generating a
sentence but same so um now I've trained
the language model it's really good at
predicting the next word now I want to
actually use it to do something more
interesting so I I want it to generate a
full sentence what I do let's say I pick
the first word the right I picked the
first word and I simply asked the
language model why what's the next word
right and the language model can do this
it can assess what's the probability
distribution here over words and it will
for example give me some some
distribution over words and I picked the
maximum one I say okay the maximum one
here is house okay the house the house
and then I go back and ask the language
model now what what's the next word then
this is see clearly you're a language
model so you can give me based on the
two previous words you can give me the
next word what's the next word and the
language was from maybe say that the
house is and so on so you can see how
you can generate a sentence by simply
basically feeding the answer that the
language model gives feeding it into the
next step of predicting so all of these
now go into the next step and once
you've predicted the next step the house
is on once you've predicted that then
you can take that and in conjunction
with everything you've predicted so far
to predict the next step so you can use
the language model that is trying to
predict the next word to predict an
entire sentence and the autoregressive
part basically means that
it's own predictions will serve as the
basis for the next predictions and this
introduces a fundamental problem namely
that I have to basically wait for one
prediction so I have to wait here for is
before I can predict on and this means
if I have a I basically can't help but
so if this is my language model it's a
box
I can't help but go to the language
model wait for a response okay then go
to the language model again wait for a
response again this is an inherently
sequential nature here where I have to
do like M steps if if M is the length of
the fun of the sentence that I want and
we can't make use of batching normally
so usually what you do during training
during training you have a whole bunch
of data right you have the cat sits on
the mat you have the house the house is
blue so I can generate just from these
two sentences I can generate a bunch of
training example I can ask I can this is
a training example where the input is
the cat and its meaning to predict sits
then this is a training example where
the input is the cat sits and language
model has to print on this here is a
training example this this is a training
example so I can junk this up into a
whole bunch of training examples and all
of those I can write I can feed in
parallel into a big matrix I can all put
them here and then run this thing
through my language model in training
mode because each of them is already
like is in the corpus I can I can I can
I didn't batch the training but I can't
batch the prediction because what we've
seen before because inherently the next
predicting the next word depends on
the last word that the model itself has
output so there is no no training corpus
around since we're we're not training
yeah so this is the fundamental problem
and these authors tackle this problem
they say how can we make this faster
this decoding so they introduced greedy
decoding here or they say okay this was
just what we've just seen the
probability of the next word is like the
the maximum the maximum log probability
here in that case if the model predicts
a lot of probability over the words that
we've input so far right and this X here
is so this is for example a translation
task a machine translation task so the X
would be the source language sentence so
maybe like a French sentence and the Y a
smaller equal to J would be the so far
decoded English sentence if we're trying
to translate to English and the Y J plus
1 would be the next word that we're
trying to predict in the English
sentence given the English sentence so
far and the French sentence the total
French sentence so greedy decoding just
does this one step after another and we
try to go to what they call block wise
parallel decoding so we can just jump to
the graphics straightaway because what
they do is pretty straight forward and
it's best illustrated in this graphic
actually so they go from the from this
situation where they already have this
here they have a saw a dog ride this is
the the sentence that has been decoded
so far and we'll we have to try to
complete it of naturally we'll ask
what's the next word but they say ok
what if we could predict not only the
next word from this but the word two
positions away or three positions away
we could do this all at the same time
all right I mean I can certainly build a
model a line
which man that doesn't only predict the
next word but predicts the word after
that as well though of course if then
the this word the predictor for this
word still only gets this as an input so
this is the important thing here so the
the part of the model that predicts the
is two words away doesn't isn't being
informed that this word is being
produced here so naturally you would
expect the quality to be worse because
the the word one position away two
positions away in three positions away
are each predicted basically
independently of each other
just from the from the source context so
there is no there is no you can't expect
like a
coherency between the words or not not a
lot so this is the the fundamental
trade-off with such a model you can
predict further into the future at the
same time but then these predictions
can't basically depend on each other and
this D creates your performance quite a
bit so what these authors do is to
remedy that they say well these these
things here we can I mean we can produce
a bunch of them right since all that's
required as an input is this we can
actually produce like we can produce a
batch of them at the same time so we can
produce one two and three words into the
future and we can do this like a hundred
times in parallel no problem all right
and we can we can sample this we don't
have to always take the most likely word
we can actually sample a bunch into the
future and this now gets smarter because
now I have a list of 100 basically
suggestions of what the continuation
here could be right I have take this not
as a given but I take these outputs as
suggestions all right and then I can
have another model that this is called
verify here I can have another model
that scores all of these different
all of these different decoding in
parallel both of these can be done by
the same model we saw the language model
can be either used to predict or to
score something since it inherently
predicts the probability of sequences or
of following words we can we can let it
out put this probability all in parallel
so this this also can count as a score
what I'm trying to say is you can see
you can since the language model is
constructed as a as outputting
probabilities anyway like such we can
use it both to predict the next word and
also if we have a suggestion we can use
it to score that and to say okay how
likely is that alright and then what we
can make sure is that the suggestion we
are looking for the suggestion basically
that has the highest score and if you
want to be really true to your original
model you say I want to look for this
suggestion that has the the maximum that
would have had the maximum score had a
decoded one by one so then basically you
you retain the original performance and
you gain a speed-up as long as the what
the greedy decoding would have produced
is in your suggestion in your box of
suggestions that you produce as long as
that's in there you gain a speed up if
that's not in there then you can always
you always have the the one word ahead
model because that's you have that
anyway you predict the next word anyway
so in case none of these suggestions
work out you still have this one word
prediction basically which is they
declare the model you started with so at
worst case you're as fast as the the
greedy model and in best case you always
your your suggestions are so good that
they're always the one that would have
been leaked
anyway so you can basically in this case
do three steps at once all right so this
verify step here is is shown here and
you see it will decode now this is just
one suggestion keep in mind they can
produce many suggestions at the same
time if if there's memory or and they
can actually they can score each of this
so they can score this they can score
this and they can score this also
independently as a batch so they can do
this in parallel and here you see yeah
here is he executed in parallel so the
model will go and will score this world
in and said ah this would have been this
is the org max of the greedy decoding
anyway and it can also score this step
and say AHA given that there is an inn
that this the the is the Arg max anyway
right and you can score this step and
say a given that there's in the the Arg
max would have been car and so that's
not bus so we reject the suggestion but
we keep that part of the suggestion and
say okay the in the is basically what
would have been decoded anyway according
to the greedy decoding so we can
basically accept this here and continue
from there this is the accept step here
so this is basically so you can see in
this one step which yeah we'll call one
decoding step we have basically done two
of the greedy decoding steps in one go
so by predicting into the future and
then selecting the one that agrees with
the original model because we can that
the fundamental thing is we can score in
parallel but we can greedily produce not
in parallel all right so they actually
push this further by also a limb
one of the one of the evaluations here
by combining basically the next predict
step with the previous verify step and
it's it's pretty cool to look at that so
we're in the same situation you have
this and you suggest this continuation
and then the scoring model again we'll
go we'll go here but while you verify
you also do the next predict at the same
time since you you've built your model
since it's the same model and this model
every time you execute it it outputs a
distribution over the next set of
positions you might as well take the
outputs of it right so when you then
decide to accept this here you will
already have the outputs computed for
the next three positions so this you can
feed directly into this next predict
step you basically don't have to execute
it you simply go to the one you've
accepted and then you look at the
outputs that you get anyway from this
model and use them so you might ask okay
which which how does a model look that
like scores and predicts into the future
and this the answer is here it's a bit
out of order I would have maybe like
this more previously but in any case
this is what they do so they they use a
transformer architecture and you have to
imagine it starts down here actually
there is a huge network down here
alright this is just the output layer so
there's a giant transformer network down
below and it produces this output
representation now normally from this
representation you would go to this
what's called P layer here this is a
output vocabulary projection so this has
one entry for each of the words in your
vocabulary so the a cat and so
and you would then for each one predict
a probability so with this
representation
you basically project it onto this
vocabulary and predicted probability
distribution over the next word but what
they do is they say no no we not only
need the next word we need the next
three words
so let's actually split this output
signal into three output signals and
they do this by introducing this this a
hidden feed-forward layer here all right
hidden transform a layer it's a it's a
hidden layer yeah we insert a single
feed-forward with hidden size
okay so they insert a hidden layer and
then they also add these skip
connections here right at the skip
connections which basically just means
they feed through this output directly
to to here and add it to that so
basically the feed-forward layer needs
to transform these this output here into
the vocabulary input one step ahead two
steps ahead and three steps out and you
can see here the those are independent
right they don't depend on each other
there's nothing feeding back p1 here
into the decision of p2 so they can be
executed in parallel but they lose the
the dependence on each other
all right so that's that's the the
architecture and you can clearly see
here it's able to predict three steps
into the future at the same time so yeah
all right so they also do different
adjustments where they say now yeah we
can also kind of sacrifice a bit of a
bit of the fidelity to the original
model by not requiring that the
basically we don't know we don't only
except when the suggestion is the
perfect best suggestion that would have
been decoded by the greedy model but
what we could do is we could just
if it's in the top K we can accept it if
it's in the if it's good enough
basically one of the suggestions that we
have is good enough then well accept it
or when you have like some sort of
distance metric they say here so the
distance between our suggestion and the
maximum so that what would have been
best by the greedy should be smaller
than some constant epsilon and that way
you can sacrifice a bit of performance
but your suggestions will be accepted
much more often and their values your
speed-up will be much higher and they
also experiment with whether or not they
should fine-tune the original model
along with their model and also the
experiment with knowledge distillation
where they basically have like some some
teacher model and you train the their
gyro model on the output of the teacher
model I don't want to go too far into
this since these these are mostly kind
of things to make it work even better
and you can see here that this is for
example a machine translation task so
this is the WMT 2014 english german
translation and there's a regularly they
get a blowy score of 26 in here a higher
is better and if you can see they get a
fairly sizable speedups by keeping the
blow scores fairly constant so they they
almost speed up by 2x but if they allow
the lowest scores to go down a bit they
get a much higher speed up of like 3 and
then if they do like distillation and
fine tuning they actually manage to keep
up the performance even though they get
very very high speed up so they get
speed ups until like 5x not dropping the
blow scores very much so that's that's
pretty impressive
another experiment they do is image
super resolution where you can see here
with regular they try to really keep
exactly the original model output and it
doesn't doesn't speed it up too much but
when they all how
for a bit of a mistake to be made so
here this is image super resolution so
values are between 0 and 255 and they
allow epsilon equals to 2 of that so
that's this kind of less than 1% error
on the individual pixel then they get a
speed-up of 7x or something like this
and you can see in this region here that
when the K is 4 and K is the number of
steps that you decode ahead so and the
mean II mean block size is 3.75 that
means on average three point seven five
steps ahead are accepted which means
basically they're their suggestions are
almost always good enough to be accepted
so they get this massive speed-up
basically of being able to jump
these decoding steps yeah so they have a
bunch of other results here they're show
their wall clock time speed up since
iteration speed up is well but if you
have to pay in huge computational cost
it's not so good but they also show that
they have a big kind of wall clock speed
up up to up to 4x here in super
resolution and over 3x in translation so
it's a pretty cool paper they give some
examples here under more tables some
examples of their super resolution and
yeah if this might be something for you
then use it it's I think it's a pretty
neat trick and yeah especially for
production systems all right that was it
but I